I found a roll of undeveloped film from
1964 in my grandparents attic 54 years
later I'm gonna try to develop it
[Music]
so here's where my involvement in the
story starts in September of 2004 my
grandmother passed away after she died
my family and I were tasked with going
through her belongings deciding what
goes where at the bottom of one of the
boxes I found an old 8 millimeter film
camera nowadays more families than ever
before are saving their good times in
movies for those who are unfamiliar with
8 millimeter cameras it was the
camcorder before they were camcorders
you'd shoot maybe 2 to 8 minutes on a
roll of film then get it developed and
play it back on a projector these
weren't for Hollywood motion pictures
they were for home movies the camera I
found was a 1963 kodak funsaver my
grandpa told me my grandmother won the
camera at the 1964 World's Fair in
Queens but he didn't recall ever seeing
her use it he let me keep it and for the
last 14 years
it's just sat on my dresser collecting
dust and I'm sure it would have
continued collecting dust but a few
months ago something happened the door
of the camera popped off and I
discovered inside was a roll of
undeveloped film
I figured if 40 plus years in a hot
attic didn't ruin the film me exposing
to the light surely would have done it
but still I was interested to see if
there was something that could have been
done a quick google search revealed my
options were incredibly limited there
are very few places that develop 8
millimeter filmed and in my initial
search I couldn't find anyone that
develops expired 8 millimeter film the
chemicals used today are different and
film deteriorates over time especially
in hot conditions like an attic if I
wanted to develop the film I was gonna
have to do it myself
well coffee has some of these
characteristics and molecules in them I
read about a group of students that
developed a development method involving
coffee grounds it's since been dubbed
Cathan all and I thought it might just
work
but it was coffee
[Music]
little bit of Drano on vitamin C doctor
Scott Williams is an inorganic chemistry
professor at Rochester Institute of
Technology and he and his students first
came up with Cathan all I've never
developed film before in my life do you
think this process is easy enough that
I'll be able to do it
oh yes simple enough that's the scary
part is I'm risking losing this footage
from nut from the early 1960s if I make
a mistake I didn't want to risk
permanently destroying this film so I
decided to do a practice run
they don't sell rolls of film that fit
my grandma's Kodak funsaver
but a friend of mine owns an old 8
millimeter camera that uses Kodak film
that still sold in stores I borrowed his
camera and I tried to develop the film
myself I was just in the dark and I
unspooled that 8 millimeter film and put
it into this which is a photo canister
it's meant for photo developing there
are essentially three steps to
developing the first step is a pre-wash
which essentially just cleans off the
film moves any sort of backing the
second one is a developer which develops
the image and the third step is a fixer
which stops the development process the
first step is going to be just hot water
and borax and that will clean off and
remove the backing of the film this
should pour out and be like really black
and I have to keep on rinsing it until
it runs clear the second step is a
mixture of vitamin C instant coffee and
super washing soda
oh man that smells that stinks
so let's do this for nine minutes so bad
last step we are gonna pour in the fixer
and it's gonna sit in there for about
five minutes should be clear moment of
truth
[Music]
oh there's definitely images what is it
though
holy that worked to my surprise it
worked kind of however the results were
far from perfect if I couldn't develop a
new roll of film perfectly what would be
the result of 54 year old Oh
that's what I learned about film rescue
International Film Rescue International
is a small operation run at a
Saskatchewan Canada I jumped on a call
with Greg the founder of film rescue
International and he said he'd tried to
develop it but he told me not to hold my
breath an attic is a terrible place to
keep film I'd be shocked if we'll be
able to get an image to expose and with
that I sent the film off to Saskatchewan
[Music]
the vault here which is a darkroom now
and then once I loaded into this ancient
machine here Jamison movie film
processor hopefully with lovely results
but most likely thought was lovely
results because this
so we're gonna do her best with us don't
know what's going to happen for sure my
guess is we're not gonna get anything
off it a few weeks later I received a
call from Greg we got an image
Greg warned me the image was far from
perfect due to the age of the film and
the chemicals he was using he was only
able to develop a black-and-white image
and because of the damage done from
exposure and the heat in the Attic
very little was visible but still he got
an image after 54 years this reel of
film was finally developed and here it
is the start of the film reel has the
most damage so we don't really see much
here but as we get further into the role
images begin to appear the sound effects
are added by me by the way most 8
millimeter film is silent this is the
1964 World's Fair
my grandpa was right I assume he's the
one filming because the woman you see in
the shot is my grandma the kids around
her are my mother my aunt and my uncle
and there they are in front of the
Unisphere which is still there just a
few minutes from where I live now I
[Music]
showed the footage to my grandpa mom
aunt and the rest of the family shortly
after receiving the footage back from
Greg that's me with a pigtail there I am
let's guys there you are oh yeah so glad
that we actually have it I would never
ever think that I'd ever see that again
and I didn't it's 150 years old honestly
to see my mother that yahoo and that
beautiful it just makes me feel like I
just need to serve so much more but just
to have that that's a blessing
I can't help but be thankful the door to
the camera popped off when it did if it
happened years later perhaps the film
would have been unsalvageable there
might not have been a place around to
develop it and I wouldn't be able to
show it to the people that lived it
[Music]
[Music]